regia mannaggia che avete cliccato evo
vi si che avete cliccato per l'anteprima
per il titolo
ho dovuto ho dovuto mettere quella
anteprima e quel titolo perché volevo
che arrivasse a tutti quanti questo
video appunto perché se aggiorno twitter
non arriva a tutti quanti
facebook non ce l'hanno tutti quanti sa
bene o male morendo
se se metti i link che non siano di
facebook e instagram
piuttosto mi ammazzo quindi sono più di
due mesi che non faccio video che è
successo ragazzi
niente il lido di compravendita di news
e per me è stata la chiusura di una
piccola e vero picco la stagione dello
show perché non ho fatto e non sto più
facendo video dopo quello è molto
semplice perché non ho più niente da
dire facciamo una premessa una cosa che
non vi ho mai detto non voglio essere
altezzoso voglio passare per uno che che
si vanta perché se sembra sempre così
quando parlo di qualcosa ma in realtà
sono con i piedi per terra molto di più
di quanto sto dicendo che vede non
scrivere i video dio mio non voglio
passare per uno che si vanta però devo
dire che da quando ho aperto canale gli
unici video che mi abbiano dato
effettiva soddisfazione personale nel
senso che il video possono piacere o non
piacere e della base di qualsiasi cosa e
intrattenimento quindi un tipo di
intrattenimento ti piace un tipo di
intrattenimento di fucka garti normale
gli unici video che io posso far vedere
a persone che non conoscono il mio
canale senza vergognarmi
sono ogni singolo video dello show
perché penso sia molto difficile per una
web star in generale non solo
e chi fa biblio ma anche chi fa altre
cose sul web da strisce di fumetti a
music all'ia foto ask star bene
ricordate le ask star gente che è
diventata famosa perché rispondeva delle
domande è molto difficile secondo me per
gran parte del materiale che uno crea
sul web fanno vedere a chi web non lo
comprende appieno
proprio la domanda base a quindi ai 500
mila follower e cosa fai per avere 500
mila follower come heidi perché hai
lascia perdere gay
ormai ho deciso vado terzo posto svelato
allora ciao gentaglia che faccio questo
video perché l'avevano già fatto però mi
sono reso conto che la grafica era
troppo alta quindi tutti quelli che
hanno aperto questo video con il mouse
tu sai quello che mi ha fatto vero non
ti sento sai quello che ti ho fatto vero
eni eni eni ci sono dei teli edifici e
difficile ma c'è un ma non avendo una
base su cui fare lo show nel senso non
c'è non lo sono io che commenta un film
per esempio quindi la base per fare i
video e il film su cupo io ci
costruiscono le battute sopra no
un video dello show parte da zero parte
da un'idea se non c'è l'idea non ci
posso costruire niente sopra e se uno
non ha un'idea o semplicemente non ha
niente da dire è meglio che non dica di
mente e quindi faccio questo video per
spiegare a voi che non sono morto non mi
ha rapito leasys non ancora
e siccome so come funziona internet e
quando uno si prende un periodo di fermo
ma non dice di prendersi un periodo di
fermo la gente ho letteralmente non
appena morto oppure semplicemente dice
bob non ha più voglia di fare video il
canale è andato vissero tutti felici e
contenti ma è giusto parlare anche di
queste cose qui anche perché non mi
ricordo di averne parlato nel canale
perché non è che mi riguardo i miei
video io anzi che imbarazzano no e ora
parliamo del futuro del canale per che
tempo fa io dissi una cosa che ritengo
tuttora ancora molto valida
una volta arrivato ai 30 anni smetterò
di essere sul web tra virgolette la
mette un po generica smettono di fare
video te e io questo 4 agosto compio
questi benedettissimo trent'anni è la
mia idea non è cambiata però lo shop
aperto le porte per tutta un'altra serie
di vero che è che qui non posso fare
devo cambiare sfondo l'ho detto l'ho
detto è la seconda bordo dobbiamo
traslocare cibo dobbiamo solo giocare di
nuovo mi dispiace
dobbiamo farlo dove non non si adesso
visitati sugli specchi mi spiego ho
fatto un errore questo è lo sfondo vero
sono mezzo metro di sfondo che errore
che ho fatto a passare da quello perché
a quello nuove sono sbagliato perché ero
convinto di riuscire a fare invece
l'ufficio non è così grande non è così
spazioso per fare una cosa del genere ma
questa volta sarà o meno rincoglionito e
quindi prenderò un vero e proprio studio
non so ancora bene come in realtà ci sto
già lavorando ma ci vuole del tempo
ovviamente perché non è come prima dove
dovevo solo allestirlo semplicemente no
quali ho capito che io determinate cose
con lo show che vorrei fare da solo non
posso farle non posso proprio con una
telecamera due luci e uno sfondo di non
abbiamo mai sarà 20 x 20 cetino no
guarda non è neanche attaccato lo sfondo
è tenuto su da delle pinze di un vecchio
chris cain che avevo io quelle pinze per
tenere il filo 20 euro
uno dice non è vero lo sfondo l'immagine
sarà costato un centinaio di euro però
120 euro totali quindi e stando sempre
dietro l'idea dei trent'anni come il
limite massimo voglio lasciare qualcosa
voglio lasciare un'impronta vera su
youtube
magari voi mi direte ma l'ha già
lasciata tu sei uno dei pionieri anche
dire che mutu 6 uno dei pionieri vuol di
non è così tanto un complimento perché i
pionieri sono quelle persone che si
hanno fatto roba ma basta e roba passate
come tu non lo che ti dice guarda che io
ho fatto la guerra
nonno era cent'anni fa la guerra va bene
basta basta anche perché molti mi
chiedevano marco sa come ma questo è un
leccio e non ci sono quasi ospiti si e
sapete perché non perché sia difficile
reperire degli ospiti famosi voi non
avete la minima idea della gente che mi
abbia chiesto di collaborare al pelo
show la minima però io non posso
invitare una persona dicendosi vieni nel
mio show e mostrargli questo sta cadendo
a pezzi
voglio farlo bene e voglio farlo più
giusto io non voglio che sia uno show
dove se tu mi sostituisce con un'altra
persona funziona nello stesso modo no
deve essere una cosa mia
e voglio fare un vero lo sciopero
leggermente più piccolo per youtube
molto più fruibile e servirà un po di
tempo e una valanga di soldi ed è per
questo che annunciò l'apertura del mio
padre per chi non lo conoscesse patron e
questo sito dove i sogni vanno a morire
no dai sto scherzando
ale mortacci io spero di riuscire a
iniziare da settembre non dal primo
settembre da metà settembre in poi pro
spero di riuscire a lavorare durante
tutto tutta l'estate però non vi voglio
promettere niente perché poi va tutto a
quindi
lasciate perdere il periodo potrebbe
essere quello e vi aggiornerò nei social
con foto dei backstage eccetera eccetera
io sono carico come uno stronzo per
questa cosa a cui io voglio tutto nel
mio show ballerine cavalli ospiti
presidenti degli stati uniti e chi più
ne ha più ne metta
grazie mille per aver seguito tutto
questo video perdonatemi per l'anteprima
per il titolo leggerissimamente click
days
quindi se non ci vediamo buongiorno
buonasera e altre citazioni di film che
non ce l'ha fatta questa pietro dai
[Musica]